[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kind of curious what the audio sounds
[Music]
what's going on you guys
i don't know if you can hear me very
well
i don't know why my audio isn't working
do i sound like i'm using this mic or do
i sound like i'm using a
a camera
i need
i need feedback i need feedback guys i
need to know what i'm using
maybe i'll i'll use my phone real quick
to see how i sound
because sometimes the chat be bugging
they don't be telling me
okay i sound fine i sound fine we are
okay
how to make sure man sometimes you guys
will let a whole podcast go through and
i'd be sounding like i'm at the end of a
tunnel
just screaming up that thing
let me grab something
what you guys doing man my my co-host
canceled on me he got stuck at work
so i guess i'm in here doing this by
myself unless fonzarelli
wants to pull up in the uh in the chat
man unless fonz wants to come in here
and talk gaming with me i'd appreciate
it i could do this by myself but you
know it's always nice to have someone
bounce back
back and forth
you know we got some we got some pretty
crazy topics to talk about
went all the way with this stuff man
went all the way with the stuff and uh
we gonna work
with this regardless if i got someone to
talk to or not
um
give me one second guys
i gotta start a zoom now i gotta start a
zoom
give me a brief moment
you guys know how it is man
i get i gotta i gotta do this at the
last minute
and now my camera's messed up because of
zoom
i gotta find out that setting
that you can
there's a setting that you what happens
is like when i go into zoom
it will
mess up to where i can't talk uh like
not necessarily talk but i can't show my
camera
so it's always like really interesting
how that works
now there is a setting to fix that
but i need to i need to find the setting
because clearly
clearly i'm unprepared today and i
wouldn't say i'm unprepared
let's let's backtrack a little bit i
know you can't see me because my camera
is frozen
but i it looks like it's frozen frozen
too like
okay okay
wait give me a
second give me a one brief moment you
guys okay there we go there we go
i got that zoom on man the zoom
is in here
now let me do the
this there we go
let me do this
bring this up
gotta make this full screen
it's crazy how much closer in
it is
when i go and zoom
when i do st other stuff it doesn't look
this this zoomed in with this zoom i
guess it would make sense that zoom
looks zoomed in but what's going on guys
man we're gonna just kick it until until
fawns is able to get in here because i
just got put him on the spot man i just
put him on the spot i got to give him
time
he can't just come in here immediately
got to give him time got to give him a
couple minutes he said a couple minutes
like five minutes
let me
fonz
there the link has been sent to you my
friend
so join whenever you can
so first thing rest in peace camera no
my camera better be up and running
hold up i'm about to check
all right see my camera up and running
you had me you had me panicking for a
second man you haven't made me think my
camera ain't working that's not right
man that's not right
so
can't wait for the halo talk yeah we're
definitely gonna break out the halo talk
man i've really enjoyed halo
i enjoy what i saw i actually got a lot
of faith in what 343 is doing over there
we just got to see them
kick it out of the park but it's got to
be a home run well
as long as the the campaign is
is fun maybe they don't have to be out
of the park but it's definitely
it's definitely kicking man it's
definitely going up there and i'm really
enjoying it you know we got this
playstation games going to pc you guys
know how it is look i will be a little
bit messy with that topic just a little
bit just a little bit all right now a
huge lot just a little bit
and you guys know how that was gonna go
you guys knew when you even walked in
here and you saw that playstation games
going to pc you knew i was going to be
messy so you don't even have there's not
even a
a surprise factor in that you know you
knew what was going down
uh do you think they're going to add in
other spartans from halo 5 uh from five
to infinite
most likely because they didn't like go
back and stop
that part from from existing
halo 5 still exists so it wouldn't
not not make sense for
them to go ahead and imply
uh to to bring in
aspects from the story
don't be messy for video games stay
clean nah man i gotta be messy man i
gotta be messy it's not gonna be like
messy messy but i still gotta be messy
look at man i'm drinking soda today
god help me
drink it soda
i ain't drunk soda in a couple days
i've cut back dramatically on soda man
don't don't start that man anyone in
there that that's young
don't start that soda thing that soda
thing will get you
that soda thing will get you soda oh
yeah yeah is it uh
so i don't know no i got i got fawns
coming man fawns is on his way
i just got to give him enough time
he got to get he got to be able to
really sit down
you know uh
build his mental state to go in this
chat with me man because you know how
how it is that i i'm apparently you know
i i i i have an effect on people he got
to build up that mental wall man he's
got to build up that mental wall
pepsi max is my life i'm 39 so i'm
halfway dead anyway well that's that's a
that's a crazy way of thinking stuff you
know cogs uh a big health nut so every
time he sees me drinking soda man he
oh again i know there's a vein in his
forehead that's like you know not to be
drinking that nonsense i should be
drinking some water i mean i got water
in there
and whiskey oh only water and whiskey i
think i would rather drink soda than
whiskey
that's just my opinion man i i don't
know like
feel like
in some way shape or form drinking soda
is not as bad as drinking whiskey not a
big alcohol drinker i got like really
bad acid reflux so it's always made that
kind of like drinking habit out of the
realm i can't ever do that
but you guys get what i'm talking about
man you guys get what i'm talking about
i can't help it but you know
it is what it is i i'm trying to be a
little bit more healthy like man
gotta survive to fable i don't know
after fable you know
up in the air man up in the air after
fable
we'll see we'll see after fail
water and whiskey you are banned from
ireland look i didn't say it
i didn't say it stuffed
stuffed sean that is a crazy name sean
stuffed
sean
pause i feel like i should have to pause
that name there needs to be some form of
pausing going on in that name
stuffed sean
that is a crazy name i like it though
man i like it what's going on black
ronin
to survive for elder scrolls 6 and 2031.
man
2031
that's
i hope not
next you should you you should you
should be ashamed of yourself for even
putting that energy out there
see my games that i uh had to live on to
was see was kingdom hearts 3 now it's
elder scrolls 6 so i have a few years to
live
yeah that's what's up man kingdom hearts
three was definitely a letdown for me
i'm not gonna lie
i didn't think it was a bad game
it just needed to be fixed what stuff
shawn says didn't fit the gamertag plus
i used to be a
uh to be fat and so
wow man wow
i want a remake of infinite um
undiscovery i have no clue what that is
no clue what that game is man i'm
surviving it's a favorable elder scrolls
six then i can die happily imagine if
they mess those games up
like you put your existence in these
games
and then they mess them up i would be so
upset
to be waiting for a game such as fable
or be waiting for a game such as elder
scrolls six
and they mess those games up
it's not right man it's not right these
people they they
they hold it a lot man they hold yeah
the first half of kingdom hearts was
disappointing which the whole end game
was cool i agree with you in in some way
shape or fashion with that i did like
like the
the
making the ultimate weapon and stuff
which i don't even think i actually made
it it's because you didn't really need
you just need to level up and a lot of
the in-game bosses were pretty easy to
beat
from what i played i know i didn't play
the expansion they had
but you know
i hope we get another fallout i think
you're going to get another fallout but
the question is is who should make
fallout chat i got a question
question
who should make the next fallout do you
think it should remain in bethesda's
court
or do you think it should be made by
someone else in the microsoft
place
we got we got some we got some uh some
stuff coming up man obsidian should make
the next fallout i don't agree with that
exile
i think they should make the next
fallout
and the reason i feel like that is
because i feel like obsidian has
they've they've deserved their
opportunity
to make another game
they deserve their opportunity to make
the the vows and they deserve the
opportunity to continue the outer worlds
franchise i think it would be very mean
and very wrong
to make them make a fallout uh you know
maybe i see uh tango said a fall like
new vegas too i could totally see that
let them do that let them do that
i i could completely be 100 okay
with someone making a what they're
making a uh a fallout new vegas to
what's going on uh fawns
fawns is still getting stuff done a
little bit
but i i could see that see i could
totally see them making that
but you know i think obsidian they need
to work on the out awards too and they
need to work on a vowed
i feel like they deserve and they have
put enough time that they deserve those
industry those those games they don't
deserve to uh you know not necessarily
be forced to make fallout but i i do
think that if you ask them to make that
they would go ahead and do it because i
do think that they're very capable of
making a fallout but i don't think that
they need to make a fallout uh and and
to be honest with you with elder scrolls
in in star field because obviously i
would expect
bethesda to want to continue the
starfield brand
so with those games i could totally see
you know that my uh bethesda isn't there
anymore
in terms of they can make that if that
makes sense to you guys
i think that
they need to focus on star field and
they need to focus on elder scrolls give
fallout to someone else
and i think i think exile entertainment
man
i can't hear you maybe it's me hold up
yes yes i can hear you yeah i can hear
you
so what's going on fawns our phones
popped up here out of nowhere in the
chat i appreciate it man like look i
could definitely do this this podcast by
myself
uh i throughout the years i've learned
it's
it gets easier and easier talking to
yourself
but it's always nice to have someone
bounce back and forth what's going on
fonzarelli
this is
uh apparently i don't have you
i gotta put you from my speakers now
they should be able to hear you
uh i apologize for that guys i i didn't
know i was gonna have someone no he's
not muted anymore he can hear me he's
loud and clear
the reason why that is because i
hopefully they can hear me no i know
they can hear you now i had the desktop
audio muted
because i didn't know i was going to
have anyone in here so i didn't think it
would really matter if they could hear
you got you
so what what's been going on fawz what's
been going on
uh nothing man i guess the big news is
the campaign trailer yesterday oh yeah
you know uh besides that i've been
playing some far cry 6.
uh when i get a chance i've been working
a lot so how how do you like the fall
cry man far cry 6 i like it i i'm a fan
of the series i think far cry 6 is is
great it's a lot of fun
um it's what i expected
i got a far cry ass far cry game
yeah and you know
because we don't really have a whole lot
of stuff to to talk about today because
besides the halo thing because a lot of
the stuff we're going to talk about it's
going to be like really really fast
it like what i don't like about this
this world that we live in now is when
it comes to games like far cry games
like halo games like gears yeah like i
feel like it's okay that they want them
games to do something different
but when it comes to games like like
call of duty games like battlefield they
can play identical like they did 10
years ago and that's fine
yep
yeah they're all about you know we need
to you know have different things going
on different mechanics and everything in
these games like with certain games and
like you said with some it's just like
we'll take it again like especially you
know
cod cod is always cod i don't care where
it is really
it's it's call of duty um far cry is
always far cry to me and i know what i'm
getting into when i play a far cry game
i think far cry 2 was the the one game
that was a bit different from the rest
um
i think that one was trying to be a
little bit different and it was great
but still first person shooter uh
you know they've got like the pets now
and stuff like that they've been doing
for what a couple of games now two or
three i'm not sure if it was they'd be
doing a few of them and like i'm not
saying that games don't need to
innervate and evolve
all i'm saying is there's a reason
people like the far cry games like look
yeah is far cry 6
um it is the new fall cry just like far
cry 5 just like far car four yes but all
i'm asking is that the games are selling
well and it's clearly building an
audience if people like that game why
does it matter
exactly a lot of people like it like
i mean somebody in the chat asked me is
it worth it yes i think it's worth it if
you're into far cry games yeah go out
and get it it's a good game it's got a
decent story too i do have to
you know point out
yes i did get the game for free
uh so you know i i get it like you got
to technically tell people that yes i
did get the game for free but i would
have easily have spent 60 dollars on
that game like the game is fun and and i
love i didn't like far cry 5 i don't
know why and what's funny is like if you
look at far cry 5 on like
like a
on the on the surface thing
the game would would have been a good
game it's just i don't know why that
game never resonated with me far cry 4 i
thought was okay
i
three is still the goat to me three is
still the goat but six is right close to
it man like that's what
is i really like the location of five
though i like that it was like pretty
much here like in america it was it was
cool to see these you know this locale
and
uh i think what maybe rubbed you the
wrong way which kind of did for me too
is there was a lot of like dream
sequences in five and there was a lot of
like hallucinate you know gins going on
like you were hallucinating a lot
and i just didn't like that kind of
stuff like
i don't like that kind of thing in games
like where you're all hallucinating and
just walking around in the days and
yeah it's it's not that fun to me but
uh that everything else about it was
pretty cool i i thought the story was
okay the colt story and everything but
but uh six is better the story is
definitely better
um
definitely and it's like i said i
enjoyed it like
for what i played of it it's just i
don't know why it just never
never resonated but man i played
not resident evil i played far cry 6
for like three days straight
like it was ridiculous me and kid smooth
played that for three days straight and
he's still playing it i've already
dropped it but he's still playing the
game
so
let's go ahead and move things a little
bit forward man first off
fonz i brought you in here it's gonna be
up to you
if big cloud wants to join is that okay
with you i don't mind i like big cloud
you want to join in here big cloud and
and talk about these playstation games
going to pc because you have been one of
the very few playstation people that
have been on board
with our logic
yes everyone else was like it's just
this game it's just that game
but you know
i i gotta say one thing about big cloud
ryan
he's a playstation dude
but i don't think he's part of the
pegasus nation
oh actually
he's definitely not part of the pegasus
exactly we still got one man like they
they they circling them though they
looking for him like they can't find him
yet but they they got the helicopter
doing the june drive-bys they got like
that spotlight looking for big cloud in
the city
yeah there you go the moment they find
them they gonna snatch them up
look but
you know let let's talk a little about
the playstation games going to pc we
finally
i've always felt like i knew
i was told like six months ago god of
war was coming out at the beginning of
the year but i didn't know when and i
didn't know where
yeah that was circulating you know from
a lot of people that were talking about
that
i've heard it two months ago
um and it was just it was funny to me
just like we heard about horizon zero
dawn early we were hearing about that
before it did nobody believed us you
know and it was just funny to me when it
finally materialized and god of war is
even bigger because god of war is
their game that that that game is
the one of the
it was voted like best game like of the
generation last year or best game
uh that ign poll that was conducted
about two weeks ago it was voted what
was it best game of the generation or of
all time i i forgot what they did
i i think it was it was it mainly was
just a popular vote i know
even though i brought this up that was
the the week that i was having like
really really bad tooth of pain
but you know we talked about it me and
hussle went over like the list
yeah i mean the list is is absolutely
ridiculous but at the end of the day you
got to understand that
a lot of the people voting in these is
probably people in their early 20s
they've never played the majority of
these games
so you know when you look into an aspect
like that it would become a popular vote
and who who's going to know more about a
crisis core or not crisis core uh chrono
trigger or who's going to know more
about four you go so clearly you're
going to see one way and not necessarily
shift the other yeah christopher jetzer
in the chat said yeah it was for all
time and you know i find that a
kind of ridiculous you know to to vote
for these newer games as best of all
time even though god of war seriously is
one of the best
in in my opinion but not the best i love
the game
um looking forward to the second but
yeah it's going to pc and i think that's
just a big heavy hitter coming going
from playstation to pc and it's got a
lot of people feeling some type of way
yeah i think what it is fawns is i think
throughout this entire time we've always
said oh you know
expect more expect more yeah people kept
saying no it's just this game no it's
just the smaller games and
i think all that did is it like look
like you know you could damage control
return on getting announced for it you
know what i'm saying you can damage
control even ratchet and clank coming to
pc
but you can't damage control their best
coming to pc so it was a lot harder for
them to explain that shout out to blaze
4k didn't he say that he was going to
get rid of his god of war uh ps4 pro
yeah he's supposed to he's supposed to
saw it in half saw it in half that was
it with it i i don't necessarily i don't
think that's necessary like i don't
think it's necessary but
he did that on erica's podcast
then you know instead of salt in half
give it to away to one of her viewers
like there you go like because i i don't
think we should just be solving
playstations of that
no like look if homeboy wants to do it
he wants to honor that because he said
he's going to do that let him salt in
half but i think
i think if erica if you asked erica
because she would be the one that you
know kind of made this this uh this
statement come to life she would
encourage you to give it to someone that
saw it in half look at nine lives no i
saw it in half
you saw it in half look man someone
could really use that playstation let's
be real here let's be 100 real here
someone can use that playstation
it's a playstation pro too it's a
playstation pro
so uh someone said burn it
well
out of curiosity i want the chat what
should blaze do to his playstation you
know i got i saw a burning i saw uh
donated saw it i personally think they
should donate it to someone there but
you know i i get it if he feels like
he's got to because he came out on his
limb and said that
do it man but what do you guys think he
should do with it but you know
let's because uh because uh
big cloud is coming in here so we're
gonna nice you know kind of skip this a
little bit
i want to talk about the the rpgs
on xbox it does look like because i want
to come back to that one big cloud's
here so it does look like that rpgs is
going someone said eat it i'm done with
you i'm not reading the chat anymore so
it does look like
that xbox is
i think xbox it has known that they
can't really necessarily compete in the
in the you know the last of this realm
i think they know that you know
it would take too much trial and error
if that makes sense
to to make that kind of game that
has took them decades to to really you
know get that type of
recipe done so i feel like microsoft's
like look we'll get a game or two cox
famous just one you know we'll get a
game or two in that genre and we'll give
that to you to keep you guys satisfied
in that genre but i feel like but what
we're gonna do
is we're gonna work on these rpgs
because
jazz corden shout out to him uh
apparently they're working on they have
got exclusivity on another studio making
an rpg
so
you got that you got fable you got
bethesda's game uh you got elder scrolls
you got uh starfield avowed outer worlds
two you got that game that uh that we
were just talking about you got the um
the game from iowa interactive i'm
assuming that's gonna be an rpg like is
it is it is it fair to say fawns that
they're coming out there and they're
gonna be like in the next three to four
years i know that sounds like a long
time and it's not really three to four
years it's gonna start it's gonna be
starting to do next year you're going to
get star filled next holiday then
probably three or four months after that
you're going to get a vow then probably
six months after that you're going to
get the outer worlds two then probably a
year and a half after that you're going
to get the next elder scrolls so is it
safe to assume fawns that they're coming
out on
their crown and they're saying if you
want to play rpgs it's got to be on xbox
in the next couple years definitely with
the western rpg market i mean i think
xbox is nailing that down there they're
they're just
look they are going to be the place for
western rpgs period i mean
look at what they got a lot of people
are downplaying star field man like they
don't understand how big this game is
going to be
this game is massive
and a lot of people are like i don't
even want to hear about it until i see
something and i'm like yeah but in the
same breath you'll say i don't care what
what next game insomniac puts out you
know they could say we're making a game
about you know corn flakes and i'm gonna
be hyped and i'm like really you could
be like that but you can't say anything
for cornflakes i'm just saying that
there's people out there like this and
it's it's crazy to me bethesda has a
pedigree in this western rpg genre they
have some great freaking games that
people love including myself i love
elder scrolls i love fallout not fallout
76 but you know they're single-player
fallout games this game is set in space
but the same type of a genre so why
can't i be excited for this
i it's it's insane like they are going
to have so many rpgs just underneath
xenomax umbrella there are the amount of
rpgs coming in and then you're talking
about io interactive you're talking
about you know this new uh wu tang
uh rpg
that's that's what jazz was talking
about and it just some crazy rpgs coming
out and xbox is going to have a lock on
all of these it's crazy
i don't think people realize how much
rpgs truly run the industry like
yes
no one's going to take away from what
playstation makes they make fantastic
games they do and every now and then
they might steal themselves the game of
the year but if you look throughout all
of history in terms of rpgs
a lot of those winners are rpgs i mean
game of years a lot of those winners are
rpgs or they're contenders at least yeah
dragon age far uh dragon age
fallout
what's your three elder scrolls like
i mean elder scrolls has won almost
every year for game of the year it's
either elder scrolls or fallout for a
couple years there it was elder scrolls
or fallout winning game of the year look
i don't even need to see anything on
starfield just yet just hearing about
what it's about and how big it is i will
tell you this i'll go out on a limb and
say it's probably going to be a game of
the year contender
i i think it's fair to see people like
to blame what happened with bethesda
and you know the uh fallout 76 which i'm
not gonna lie that was atrocious they
should be ashamed of themselves for how
that game came out but we can't
look at the beginning but not look at
the end i know i don't like how they're
doing these type of games as a service
and i think they should be more i think
they should be more
honest when it comes to stuff like this
i think that preview program needs to be
used more
and i think that uh companies need to
stop trying to you know not use preview
program but at the end of the day i
don't blame them
for
you doing what they're doing like at the
end of the day when it comes to rpgs if
they put that in the preview program
when it comes to something like like a
fallout 76 i think it would have took a
lot better in terms of how that game was
perceived than just popping that game
out and be like yo
we're gonna do this and i think that's
the biggest issue i think the biggest
issue is that we need to
we need to hold these publishers
more responsible
and
when they release a broken game
and i don't think that just because that
game was a little bit down doesn't mean
that the next fallout by bethesda is
going to be down the next elder scrolls
game star field sure they're going to be
buggy but the difference between fallout
76 and fallout 4 and uh fallout 3 in
elder scrolls five skyrim is the bugs
were there but the enjoyment outweighed
the bugs by far fallout 76 there was
nothing to do
so all you saw was the bugs what's going
on big cloud he's finally joined uh
what's what's going on [ __ ] club
can you guys hear me
yes we can hear you oh what's up what's
up what's up
so what what what's what's going on with
you [ __ ] clown
ah chillin just uh you know sitting on
the throne
watching everybody's little
glass houses uh fall to pieces you know
oh dudes dudes that want to put people
like me in boxes because you know i hang
out aside from just playstation guys you
know those dudes oh god awards never
going to pc oh god a war would ever
happen oh return it's never going to
happen oh andre's never going to have
you know these guys you know when you
check their profiles they haven't even
beaten those damn games so it's like
what's going on here
yeah
i i've never known it's been a funny
it's been a funny very very funny week
and obviously with the halo thing uh a
lot of people are now finding something
else to uh project that
i i think i think addict touched on it
earlier uh ryan but what's even funnier
is when you hear about this stuff months
prior and then it you know you you're
waiting for it to happen and you're just
like just sitting there smiling in your
head going these guys are just going to
melt
and sure enough they do
when it happened i just like
and the reason why i take some joy in
that is not because i'm a console where
i could give a [ __ ] about this excuse me
i could give a damn about this console
war
but
i have so many dudes that attack me all
the time
and and even when i tell a joke or say a
joke or something they take it so
seriously and think i'm console warring
no i could care less about your plastic
war
i like to have fun with this stuff
sometimes
so i wouldn't understand that font and
i'm glad you brought that up a lot of
people really don't understand that we
are so past
this console we're bullshitting so dumb
like we're actually having fun with our
platforms i see you interviewing people
you see me
really going out here interviewing
people i got something big for november
5th
and i told you i don't know if dealer
told you but i shared this
yesterday i don't know if he told you no
no i'll be helping out ign in a project
nice nice good job
congrats man that's awesome so yeah i
don't i don't have time for just it's
not like i don't care at all i just
don't i just don't care no i can't i
can't i
i don't care at all
yeah it's like
it's funny
i see i want to do this i see people on
twitter always like oh we need the new
xbox blood these new xbox people are
defeated we just don't care anymore we
don't care i i've dealt with all of this
nonsense that was happening for years
and i've just gotten to the point where
i'm just like stay over there and do
your console war stuff now i ain't gonna
lie
occasionally a dude will join the spaces
you know occasionally i'll get bored and
i'll get weak and i want to listen to
some stuff oh i listen to it it's crazy
you will rarely see me
hit that request button
because i don't care what's being talked
about i just want to hear the opinions
on stuff now i i literally hear people
in these spaces almost getting dif like
they want to get into fist fights over
these games and i'm just like it's not
even that serious people you know videos
killing me though uh dudes want to just
like i never thought in a million years
i would have people especially dudes who
actually work for living right
come at you and go um oh having games at
a discounted price or having games you
know just be cheaper is a bad thing for
the industry and they're like oh wow we
paid seventy dollars for product i'm
sitting going
um
okay uh here's the thing it's like
you're saying group of people
who would prefer it to be cheaper and
this is why things are looked at as a
deal and things will look that better on
one side or versus the other 70
i will add a bigger group a bigger group
of people want it cheaper yeah this is a
small minority we're in the minority
when it comes to the gaming community on
twitter
yeah
we are i need to understand
i just got done we talked to kate gager
i know yeah i know kate yeager uh that's
right you know refresh bounce from
okay we had her on the show uh on our
last uh show friday we had like this
crazy like conversation but
what she said was perfect
about the whole thing it's not
it's really not as deep as she was this
she told us about phil and how phil
looks at the whole situation and it's
like
i believe her personally i really do
believe everything she said it's not
it's not as deep as what people think it
is it's
petty at this point for a lot of people
i think people need to realize that like
the cons of war stuff's funny to a point
but i feel like we've been way past that
point where people get disrespectful for
no reason
people like
look i've always said when it comes to
reviews and stuff
if you feel like someone isn't beating
these games and they're reviewing them
just don't support their content don't
go to their their stuff but now we are
on a witch hunt
uh
people are demanding
your your your gamer tag and what
trophies you've beed and what
achievements you've unlocked and i i put
on twitter and people got really upset
with me you don't owe these people
nothing
if they want you to demand your
criterias to talk about games you don't
owe them anything
because what's funny is the same people
telling you not to to save on a deal the
same people are telling you not to do
game pass the same people are telling
you this stuff are always on that
website every black friday every cyber
monday trying to get a better deal but
when it comes to that they'll save money
on a tv but not games
not to mention the same people are the
same people who are maybe asking for
your gamer tag to check your credentials
because you're talking about a
particular game they want to make sure
you you've played but these same people
talk about xbox daily and don't even own
an xbox oh
how do you like that
i said i said that on twitter too once
it's just like look like
if you think someone's being fr being
like a fraud then like
that's all you have to okay mental note
don't don't watch his content mental
note don't don't follow him on twitter
but instead of just doing something that
simple what do you guys do
you give them more what's funny is
people in this community
that had that people have always felt
like have not been true they've always
been fraudulent the reason they're still
around is you keep giving them you keep
giving them highlight weekly
so it's just like if you don't support
something don't watch it
unfollow someone hell i won't block
people most of the time i'll just mute
you but the only time i block you is if
i see your stuff pop up because too many
people are sharing your stuff that's
when i'll block you because at that
point it's just like look like i got
nothing against you i just don't want to
see your tweets uh but you know it is
what it is you know we ain't gonna go
too much into that it's like all i say
in the chat man if you don't like
someone just don't
don't support them you don't have to go
on witch hunts you don't have to attack
people you don't have to demand their
their stuff i know a lot of people got
upset with the individual from ign that
you know stated he loved his xbox and
they went there and they said that he's
not been on it in two weeks look i will
admit that looks shady but is that shady
enough does that do live in my mind
enough for me to make crazy amounts of
tweets make videos no
but sometimes sometimes my xbox says i
haven't turned it on in a month but i've
been playing every day i just show
offline yeah you show offline yeah i
don't know
a month ago yeah i don't know what's
going on there maybe
i do know he reviews games a lot so
maybe he appears offline a lot um i
don't know what anything over there all
i can see is it did say the individual's
offline i don't know if that was a
hiccup on xbox live's part but that's
not really part of the conversation
mainly this conversation was instead of
just telling yourself you didn't like
this dude's content they attacked him on
twitter for like two weeks over it but
you know let's let's go back they gotta
go that extra miles cloud chase and
that's all it is
yeah i do think uh cloud is yeah i'm
saying like
hell yeah oh yeah that's all it is they
want to be seen so so bad
and um
[Music]
it's bad it's crazy how far don't you
like ryan don't you like how they love
or how they hate digital foundry and
then they love them
you know what i love about this too
that's the same thing they feel about
sony what did they say when god of war
went to pc yeah i know yeah the damage
controls gotta go jim ryan's gotta go
right you got dudes with damage control
saying oh well it's a four year it's a
four or five year old game right funds
and then you got the other one saying
i'm done with playstation i'm not buying
another one one dude said i spent
fifteen hundred dollars on a ps5 and i
got an error
i was sitting there going okay so you
spend 1500 on a damn ps5 and you were
upset because one game because this
game's going to pc mind you shouldn't
bother you at all because
this is just future-proof in the next
one
yeah but he's mad about this he's like
oh yeah my game's going you know this
game's going this i'm doing playstation
but you know what he did fonz
he started tweeting so he's like he's
like [ __ ] you so [ __ ] you but as soon as
sony announced that there was going to
be a state of play tomorrow
he stopped yeah all these dudes are
trained i said this one game on daily a
lot of dudes don't catch on to this like
you know that movie jelly with jelly
where it's called unleashed like the dog
dana dog they're trained like danny the
dog it's like they got the perfect beat
to get you to get that attention where
they want you to put that attention
every time sony drops a tweet saying
state of play all of a sudden
everybody's got amnesia they're not done
with playstation they want to be
watching the next one i might lie i
thought you were done
i thought you hate the company i thought
jim ryan's got to go
it's uh the funny thing is you know i
definitely want to move on after this
but the the funny thing is
i remember when
playstation games were going to pc and
it was very clear
you know the same people telling me to
stand up uh for for microsoft not making
quote-unquote games which we were always
saying they need to make better games
you all sell your xbox
they didn't sell their playstation like
but you know we're going to move past
that because i don't want to be too much
into that but you know
let let's go to the the playstation top
act actually like obviously we we saw
god of war go to place that uh god of
war is going to bc
um i think
i think we can all agree once we saw god
of war go it's a wrap like that if
they're willing to take god of war
because it's always a a matter of what
game they're going to do on that what
game are they going to do on this but
once you see god of war
it's a wrap then because people know
that that's what's going to happen i
think once we finally see something like
god of war go to pc everyone in this
community
yeah can agree that anything can go day
day is up for up for debate you know
obviously i think that's gonna be at the
end and kate brought that up uh addict i
don't wanna cut you out but she brought
that up like me we all said it like
probably at the end of this generation
that budge on day and date probably will
you know what i mean will probably be
there or that line will be crossed at
that point you know that you know that
uh original last of us remake coming
uh-huh
i bet you it goes to bc well there's a
reason why it's like you can't are you
caught on to this one there's a reason
why there's a delete for this let's keep
in mind why aren't we getting updates on
this they're talking about they're just
now starting factions which you may be
just now starting factions yeah actually
should have been done
so that means that more than likely
you're going to see a collection or a
night clutch but a director's cut of
that right back and then you're going to
see that go to pc
yeah especially the last of us too
you're going to see a director's cut
then it's going to be linked with pc
through factions
it is kind of crazy that
they're just now doing factions like
yeah one would think factions would have
been done a long time i mean when when
did uh
last of us come out
last of us came out at the end of the
playstation 3 which is like 2013. no
last of us two
oh last was two last weeks two came out
2020
or 20 20 20 20. yeah 2019 2020
because to me
i'm starting to think that
maybe it's debatable that there wasn't
even going to be a factions
like i'm starting to think that
yeah the only reason they they ramped up
and put a team together to make factions
is because
they got so much backlash like i'm
starting to think that they cancelled
factions somewhere in the development
for the last of us and they didn't think
that they thought that would get some
pushback but not as much pushback as
they got but when they got the pushback
okay let's get people back on this
clearly they wanted because to me if it
was like they said and they were just
working on it i feel like it wouldn't
have took this long
but to me it feels like they it's taking
way longer than it should
no
i'll get it yeah
it's possible man it's definitely
possible because i don't even think they
knew or they believed that uh fascist
was gonna be a sleeper hit for him in a
sense
on the uh well ps4 i know the
the original last of us multiplayer was
actually
well received people liked it a lot yeah
it was a sleep bit yeah so
i'll be there people are waiting for
this for sure but uh i don't know how
long they're gonna keep waiting uh
i i don't know why it's taking so long
but they're gonna wait as long as uh the
the people will let them wait oh bro
they're waiting for those next they'll
probably announce this uh as soon as
they're ready to share those official
uh new sales numbers of the unit i just
find it a little convenient that sony
santa monica announces as soon as they
go hey guys we sold they under 20
million units of god of war 2018
now guess what it's on pc so i'm pretty
sure they're gonna who knows we could
see factions probably
maybe something you know next e3 who
knows
i don't expect that the state of flat i
think it's all third-party again just
because i don't think we'll see i think
we'll see final fantasy 16 we'll see
final fantasy you saw the leaks you saw
the league stop
no no i i
someone said that in my stream yesterday
there's it was it was it was leaked
i'm just assuming that final fantasy 16
would be there because it wasn't at
their last event mm-hmm it's a final
fantasy it said uh that was going to be
there it said it was going to be you
know that game to chia or chia whatever
that's going to that little anime
looking game
oh
yeah yeah that fancy anime looking uh
yeah that's gonna be there supposedly
gonna be some other uh
some other stuff but it was mostly a
therapist he said some other stuff
because it's really not there it's not
it's not important it's not a good
looking elite really i because i keep
hearing some big stuff is going to be
announced um unless they changed the
last minute from what i saw in that
league did you see hellblade 2
no
no
not even that huh
wow
we'll see they might be covering
something up you never know i mean i
hope so but a lot of these leaks funds
you already know a lot of them
have been very accurate
it depends on who it comes from like
part of you is adding so much more
credence to the bloodborne rumors which
we kind of already knew was what's going
to happen what is that bloodborne are
they saying remaster on that so it's
going to be a remaster for ps5 or remake
for ps5 i think it's remastered for ps5
there's gonna be a sequel and then uh
that's then they also said that the pc
port is done this courtesy of column
okay so it's not a remake okay that's
the one i was questioning i was like why
make a remake just remaster it just you
know yeah make it 60 frames
we're going to remaster with uh probably
haptic supports and they'll just do like
better frame 60 and still fix the issue
yeah i've heard the developers say that
haptics is not something that's really
hard to you know implement into these
games so it's not like it's something
revolutionary like yeah some people just
i i really can't stand when i hear
you're still going to pay this boy
yeah for haptic [ __ ]
yeah i'm so sorry feedback
basic features
yeah i mean when it comes down to it
like
i just get really annoyed with with
stuff like this because it's just like
look like
i get it
yeah they got they got your passion man
they got it they're going to manipulate
you with it but it's just like we could
call it out and still support it
like like
if you want to play ghost with sashimi
it's like i said on iop if you want to
go out there and spend that money i'm
not going to blame you they got your
your hobby
it's not like you're not not going to
play games
but it's just like but to but to say
it's okay
into that's a different thing
yeah like it's like man they are
charging you ten dollars to activate the
playstation 5 features that they
promoted the ps5 with that you should
just naturally get games that support
that feature off the rip just by turning
your ps5 on you shouldn't have to pay
for that here's the funny thing about
the situation let's say the rolls of
reverse
what do you think the playstation dudes
would say to xbox that's the case oh you
know what we don't even know
what i'm saying like they don't look
they don't look at both sides of the
point i just laugh at it i'm like bro
there should have been better sisters in
play for this it's like
iop
we're big on giving back to the
community you know
uh every time there's a big sell solve
will send me a certain amount of money
where you know i just go in there i pick
up games i think people really enjoy and
we give them away throughout the couple
months but
people ask what attic why don't you guys
got playstation because playstation
doesn't have gifting
playstation
that's true 21 and they still don't have
gifting but and i get it games are
important games are
all be all center of attention but we
need to stop having this mentality that
we can't call them out for their
features
yeah they don't have gifting in 2021 why
the hell do you have a wish list system
but no gifting i i don't understand that
[ __ ] at all you know excuse me but i
don't understand i don't understand it
on the ps5 store
and you know i want a console for
everything for the features for the
social aspect for the games i and if i
feel like one is lacking i'ma call you
out
and i i get really annoyed that you
can't call sony out for anything you
really can't
because the moment you call them up but
we got these games though
it's like okay that's cool i mean can
you sound like a nintendo fan at that
point you know i mean like that's what
you notice that you sound like a
nintendo fan like oh well nintendo's got
these games
sure nintendo's got those games but
nintendo was far behind
in basics i mean you know how many
people including myself i'll say yeah it
is about the games with this hobby but
there's so many quality of life features
on the xbox that you don't get anywhere
else
for console wise anyway and that's the
thing
like i love those features on that
console that's why i'll say for me
series x is the better console
may not have the better games for me
personally but i love the concept you
love it for the simplistic nature i love
the console
i think when it comes down to it like
this this n64 thing people attacked
before i know we look chat i know we
going off the rails every five seconds i
can't help it man
i know when it comes to the n64 feature
i know that is
[ __ ] i'm gonna say it i know i
shouldn't cuss
but i know it it it it's a poor taste
but guess what i'm gonna play that zelda
ocarina of time on that switch and there
ain't nothing in this world that's gonna
stop me i'm not ambulating the game yeah
you can you can get that is it
remastered no
so it's what 480p
yeah it's the emulator
you're basically paying you're basically
paying fifty dollars to play the
emulated version yeah
might as well the emulator
look
okay
i don't need your opinions on the matter
okay
i i don't need you breeding up the 460p
[Music]
aspect
i'ma still play it
i'm gonna stream it ocarina
is the best zelda in my opinion
because they have this
they have this new thing on iowa people
just buy it on steam deck but just get a
steam deck come on make your life easier
i have this i have this new thing
where people
on iop
are trying to get me to play these old
ass games that i was not around for
tetris so yes saab said bubble bobble he
wants you to play bubble bobble
you do not want to play bubble ball you
definitely don't want to play what is
bubble bottle it's basically a puzzle
game with these little balls that you
shoot up it kind of you connect the
colors and stuff it's it's like the most
puzzle
bubble bottle hold on
[Laughter]
it was on the nes bubbles
yeah you're gonna love that one
it a nes game yes yes it's nes
all right
there ain't no way you guys are asking
me to play this game
no way
hold up hold up
hold up
ain't no way yeah somebody said in the
chat it was fire it had co-op
why don't you co-op there you got to
look this up with jason b
i got it up on the screen right now this
is not what he wants me to play that's
the thing bubble bobble was okay back
then
yeah
this does not look appealing solve
this dude doesn't solve hates me he
secretly hates me so i'm just doing that
purposely i saw that list of games i'm
like you're not gonna make him play
those are you so yeah we're trying
soft secretly hates me that's what's
going on here he secretly hates me
oh my god soft yeah so i was a good dude
i like saw yeah but
you know we we we ain't gonna talk about
that game man they ain't happening that
ain't happening
but you know let let's let's let's roll
back to what was going man you know
i think really much to say we knew this
was coming everyone else has said it
wasn't coming god of war is on coming to
pc relatively fast too like what two
months a month
it's in january isn't it
it was before
it was it was before uh
um before
unchartered
it's kind of crazy how quick that
happened
but i'm telling you the the door is open
there's a lot more games that come you
already know when you put your staple on
us when on another platform
there is nothing out of reach at this
point and when when you're spiderman
when the company has its own steam
store or area yeah you know i said that
dude's like it doesn't mean nothing
you're right yeah it doesn't mean
anything okay okay is that why they're
already testing their deals they were
testing deals uh for days gone on steam
yeah
that's like come on man they they know
what they're doing and by the way didn't
days gone surpass the sales of the ps4
on on pc already it's built over a
million yeah it's all pretty well yeah
no oh it just sold a million oh i
thought well i don't know i didn't look
i didn't look i didn't look at that i
think it sold more on pc
yeah i think it did
sony still gonna give them a nice secret
but they didn't sell they're not gonna
sell games at seventy dollars over there
that's for sure yeah that's why
no they're gonna just sell it at 50.
they know that's the sweet spot for pc
at least yeah you know while the bells
and whistles they're offering so at this
point in time pretty much all the pc
dudes are about to get their wish like
for example spider-man we know it it's
gonna drop on pc at this point and the
funny thing about pc i brought this up
with kate i'm bringing this up you guys
so you guys already know uh tom holland
in the mcu this is his last film pretty
much with marvel
do you guys think
unless unless this game is going to pc
right do you guys think that that's part
of a deal now where if that goes to pc
they'll sign him back on to do another
film and tie venom
into the mcu
well and tomorrow was into you because i
think there's there's parts to this why
they're they're quiet okay
i think i think money money talks when
his contract is up for spider-man
if they offer him another contract which
they're going to there ain't no way that
kid ain't taking that contract
yeah he's playing
and i know a lot of people are very up
in the air on his portray of spider-man
but i actually like it i don't think
he's better than the previous ones in
one aspect but i think he's the better
overall as spider-man and peter parker
yeah he he's he's about about there uh
in terms of like everything that the
personality the the wit everything he's
got because i've always felt like the
original spider-man uh toby maguire
uh what i probably was the original the
one that i consider the original i've
always thought like he was toby
yeah i always thought that like
he was good in one aspect but not the
other and i thought you know jay i
thought um andrew was good
at spider-man but not peter parker and i
don't think
i don't think i don't think that um
nobody does it yeah i don't think he
does any of them do any better like i
don't think he plays a peter parker
better than uh toby maguire and i don't
think he plays spider-man better than
andrew but i think he plays them both
better than both of them did
like because i see what you're saying
it kind of evils out okay i might not do
spider-man as good as andrew did but i
do peter better than andrew did i might
not do
peter better than toby did but i do
spider-man better than toby did so i i
think it levels it out because at the
end of the day you can do one aspect
really good but if you
if you mess up the other aspect does it
really matter what you did good yeah you
don't yeah that's true yeah one thing i
will say though about tom holland though
is i don't like his nathan drake i don't
yeah yeah i think he looks too young and
he just doesn't i don't know how to play
[ __ ] i just think that's it i don't
think that's his fault he's just playing
no no it's not his fault of course but
it's the fault of the you know the
the directors and your producers and
stuff that chose him
yeah i don't know why they said
they could have got um gosh there's so
many people they get a picture no tom
cruise is way too old for that
the dude who played the um that short
film version of
just a guy that's like maybe in his
early 30s or something to play the role
it would just fit more
somebody bigger too tom holland always
looks really small yeah so why is uh
wahlberg sully
i uh i don't know
i definitely apologize uh we did get a
two dollar superchat from eric83 it was
a couple minutes ago
the conversation was so good i
completely forgot but i'm gonna get you
right now man i would rather have
quality versus quantity i agree but i do
think that in gaming we need a little
bit of both
it's just the quality can't be way down
like you know and i think people don't
realize
when it comes to games i don't think
people realize how much
marketing is almost
half the budget of almost every game
like especially aaa games i don't think
people realize how much money is spent
on marketing
and i do think something like game pass
makes it easier for them to do stuff
that is
doesn't necessarily require a whole lot
of marketing you know i do think they
still need a market don't get me wrong
they need a market but i don't think
because of something like game pass
instead of having an entire marketing
campaign off of a game they can have a
game pass commercial that markets the
whole service but it's like halo themed
so i think it's easier to market game
pass
in themed ways than it is to market
individual games and it's gonna it's
gonna probably reduce the amount of
money they spend on marketing overall
like drastically yeah
but you know let's
let's let's get you know
yeah let's get to
the bread and butter of the podcast the
halo infinite story breakdown
big cloud
you in the hot seat for a minute cause
instead of taking it in
the the the like i watched it
immediately take it to those youtube
streets being messed up
immediately
so we're going to get you against that
we're going to get that you want me to
go and start yeah
so yeah the halo infinite campaign if
you watch the video watch my stream
because i know where all my dislikes
came from
but i watched this shirt watch this live
video i thought it looked good i even
phrased it i said the gameplay the
grappling cook all that stuff is cool
you're really pushing the sandbox
two different extremes with this it
looks good
personally though um
certain decisions involved in that even
dealer called this out especially at the
end
why is that even in the trailer
for this when you know how social media
works now people are going to just
you know break this stuff apart and look
at it for example if you guys remember
the uh i've got the name of the little
soldier that they show you at the
trailer what's that thing called the s
that soldier that little alien soldier
thing that generally i don't talk to i
don't know what he is the guy who looked
yeah the one that looked all untextured
not the not correct
yeah that thing the sandra game
and that's not its name i'm just saying
it's something like that yeah but
whatever that guy was that d that little
alien uh uh creature whatever
when we that version of them that we saw
in the last trailer
is actually still in the is that still
in here but it was the hologram
and then they showed you the cgi version
of it everybody said okay they fixed it
it looks better in the cgi version only
for them to confirm that that not only
is that not what you guys are getting on
the console it's not an engine it's cgi
it's like
why y'all why are y'all putting
yourselves in this situation you already
know the internet is going to go in and
pick this apart and go yo guys see the
series x it can't do this and even deal
that's not going to do about this the
series is capable of giving you an image
like that
so why are we even going on the social
media why are we even putting ourselves
in a situation like this we can't show
it off and mind you this comes after ray
tracing is confirmed not to be honored
for the record don't care it's about
that there's no one out there but ray
trace is not preferred for the um the
game now and they remove online co-op so
it's like bro
what what exactly are we doing here
sure gameplay looks good
that's a big thumbs up it looks great
they improved on all that stuff
but when we go to presentation the game
looks great at the start of that trailer
you can't deny it it looks great the the
foliage all that stuff
but then it starts cutting to different
parts of this and it doesn't look as
good
pre present uh present presentation why
it doesn't look that good there's
certain things
halo looked like really inconsistent in
certain things yes
uh i think
the highlight of it was the gameplay
uh but you know the the graphics are
definitely inconsistent some of like
especially like the environmental look
really nice uh but you know
here's my thing with
putting the cgi scene in there i love
that they're being transparent and the
developer came out there and was like
look
this is
cgi it's not in-game but then part of me
is like
fam why you why you on twitter talking
like i'm like part of me is like i need
you to be
better in terms of being transparent the
other part of me is like get off of
twitter
i'm like bro delete this comment you're
about to just sit the the damn drones at
you in droves just for this comment like
guys uh
yeah by the way uh
that that left version the cgi it's not
a ninja i'm like come on man
like right when everybody's praising you
why why why do that
i think the game looks really solid for
what they were going for yeah it was
fine old halo style arch style uh
updated refreshed it yeah i it looked
good for that look really good solid but
what you look like certain ways no
no but there's certain things about it
that they chose to do that i really
don't understand and it was stuff to do
with animations
there was some animations that were like
30 frames
where everything else the presentation
60 frames a game 60 frames but there are
certain aspects of it
in in less frames and and you could
totally see it
um
there was that one moment where they
dropped the pelican
or the pelicans
really really
kind of bounced around and the sparks on
that thing yeah
and the wheel you know it looked like
this yeah
it didn't even yes game it wasn't it's
like it's like bro
franchise i didn't even look at i didn't
even look at the
the the the uh you know the sparks i
didn't even notice that i just didn't
like how that thing was dropped man like
you bounced off the ground yeah i was
like i was like i was like i don't know
anything about developing i'm gonna
point that out right now but it's like
man why didn't you just have that thing
on and it lowered itself down you know
what i'm saying like and then it just
gently like dude it looked crazy when
that thing was put down and it bounced
off the ground would you know
these weird sparks oh man
i do think in a realm of of the reality
that they are in that would make the
most sense because like if you're
actually
calling for this stuff and you're in the
middle of like a battlefield it's not
going to you know just they're not going
to be able to put it down like gently
like that wait wait wait wait wait wait
kids move in the chat said that was for
comedic relief i don't think so i don't
know
is it a big deal
no no it's not a big deal on the grand
scheme of things
i'm telling you guys it looked good for
what they were going for is it a
graphical showcase no
it's not it's definitely not does it
look better than it did last year yes
yes big improvement but it's still that
halo art style that some of us including
myself just didn't really care to see
yeah i wanted to see something new
i wanted to see that really push the box
you know i wanted to see that dumb dumb
graphics
hold up hold on let me know what they
were going for let me get these super
chats cause i gotta we gotta talk about
the second super chat so we got five
dollar super chat from flame game looked
incredible but i'm still waiting till
around june i want to play it with
friends to see the ray tracing xbox
themselves uh tower yeah i agree with
you if if you feel like i can't wait i i
what i saw i was absolutely
thrilled you know what and at the end of
the day i'm not gonna just hold my
tongue if i didn't like something i'm
gonna tell you didn't mean i didn't like
what i saw it just meant like exactly
you know like we're joining things out
we're pointing out obvious stuff
we're pointing things out dropping the
pelican or whatever that was called i
think that's a yeah the pelican was
dropping that what is that little ship
called
like a tetris ball
i wasn't feeling too much but you know
i understand that i get it
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna hold my
opinion because of how good the game
looked besides that then we got a two
dollar super from dawn to taku y'all
complaining about how physics works
dude come on man oh here we
go you can't tell me that seeing that
seeing that piece of machinery bounce
off the off the floor like that like i
said like it was a basketball like
you're just throwing it on the floor
like come on man
nobody expected this to look drastically
different if you did you're smoking
something nobody was saying that and i
knew what i was getting i knew this is
basically what we'd get with better
lighting you know same thing we saw last
year better lighting some better
textures that's what we got yeah it
looks great
it looks great for what they were going
for
and i think it looks fun i think it
looks like a blast but there is things
that i'm kind of skeptical about with
the game
and that being their direction of being
live service open world
i don't know how that's going to
translate into a halo game no hold on we
shall see they're not even like trying
to hide it too they're just i don't
throwing it actually yeah i don't
normally read non-super chats uh because
it interrupts the show but this this is
c says guys what is wrong with you every
vehicle drops in halo
uh always to say it's bounces because of
metal look we are not saying the
balancing is the issue we're saying the
way they did that's the issue
so you mean to tell me
that i have to get a vehicle
and that shit's already busted like you
needed to tell me that i come in the
gate with a busted vehicle because they
couldn't drive that
safely down on the ground
like i ain't feeling that guys
i wanted that vehicle to kind of hover
down and gently put itself on the ground
i get it it's the battlefield
it's not realistic but guess what we
playing a video game
no one in this chat can look at that
okay and i see kids move super chat i
ain't looked at it because i have a
feeling it's about to be some
off-the-wall stuff we're about to read
that here in a second but
no one could tell me you saw that you
saw the way that vehicle dropped to the
ground and you looked at your friend or
you talked to someone at the in the
party said that's hot it wasn't
yeah those sparks were fired nobody said
that nobody said that
but hey you know what i did say was a
fire it was awesome to see is that
every time i see them use the grapple
hook yeah it looks yeah so much fun man
did you see that thing in the
multiplayer he knocked the car across
the map he like looked and got to the
flag yeah that opens up a lot of cool
like possibilities in the game which i
like the only thing i wish it would have
you know
we can do in the multiplayer anyway i
hope in single player you get to use the
grapple hook as much as you want i hope
you can i think you can i think it's got
to cool down but i don't think it goes
away yeah yeah look man people really
clowning over me having an issue with
the way this this vehicle driving tell
us
dude's like you're nitpicking we're not
nipping we're just calling out the
obvious
you guys act like i'm up here you guys
act like i'm up here and i'm like you
know i agree
we are not picking okay you know we are
nitpicking but we're allowed to do that
chat i'ma stand on my ground i ain't
buying this game i ain't doing it i'm
done i'm over nah i can't beat that one
we're attacking halo in a bad
perspective
i loved everything i saw
maybe a little bit less the ubisoft
stuff but i'm willing to try it because
it's halo it's not it's not far cry and
i love far cry it's just i just played
far cry 6
so like i'm already like like kind of
like trying to to get that far cry
formula out of myself and then i see
halo doing something similar that
doesn't necessarily mean it's bad i feel
like maybe that formula
made the halo way would actually work
better so
because why is everybody so upset with
this about it it's it's literally just
like guys what are we doing
that we're just talking about it's like
look if you want to see
if you want to hear about just
everything glowing and oh my god it's
just the most amazing thing i've ever
seen
i i don't know what to tell you i don't
think there's a podcast out there that
would do that with what we saw oh
they're they're pockets they'll do that
or maybe there are yeah
we're being honest y'all want honest
opinions
because i know you guys have been a
little bit extra here
um
i'm done with this fighting thing so
we're going to put this up on the screen
there we go
we about to put this this game up on the
screen man there we go first off first
thing we're going to do
is we're gonna see what you guys keep
making fun of me over
all right so i i'm gonna look okay now
now all right now keep in mind here here
is what we are talking about i know
every one of you in this chat is
co-signing this and i ain't feeling this
chat i ain't feeling the cosign of the
bouncing whatever this is called i don't
know it's a wasp or a hornet or
something we'll get to the super chats
in a minute man we gonna nitpick the
hell exactly so why not i am choosing
violence nine lies we choosing violence
so look at this
first off
bam why is that acceptable to me
look at that let's let's let's do it
again let's look at that again because i
don't think you guys are paying
attention look at this oh my god sparks
look at how this thing is falling down
man look look it comes it almost flips
on its side
weight my dude i'm not okay with having
a ship that's already been damaged just
because they dropped it down if this was
it is realistic in a battle scenario but
do you see anyone shooting me here like
here's my thing if this was in the real
world that pilot would be fired
oh my look at that like i don't
understand how people feel like this
right here is except look at that like
look how much it bounces up my dudes
look at this
somebody said todd howard says it would
say that that was 36 times the detail oh
he probably would look look this thing
literally if it would have hit
just a little bit differently this thing
would have flipped look at this it is
almost flipped i paused it this damn
thing almost flipped over upside down
and people saying this is cool this is
hot this is why couldn't they have added
like a landing gear and it just like
bounced slowly you know as it hit or
like a gravitational thing you know i
mean like it stops
just turn on its engines let the engines
bring it down safely to the yeah there
you go like like i i don't get why this
is such a a big thing i don't we're
going to get to these super chats real
quick because i i got something to say
to kid smooth so uh let let me bring it
up oh smooth probably dipped no one's
smoothie dipped
six times the detail
look it's all jokes like i'm still
getting the game it is it is
but look man halo still getting this
smoke if i don't like something it's
still getting smoked of course
all right so kid smooth the 5 super chat
how did y'all play the game last month
and expect the campaign to look
drastically different
didn't
they no one said anything about it yeah
i don't even know
where look me expecting the ship that i
called in to come in
non-damaged is it here's here's the
thing addict i was seeing some people
expecting a drastic difference on
twitter i i saw some xbox folks that
were thinking they were overhauling the
graphics
completely and i'm like no
it's not happening yeah
all right so uh let's let's get the next
one so we got a five dollar subject from
gamer by choice the gravity of the world
would uh determine if it bounces world
physics the phys the the the car
bouncing is not the issue the issue to
me is how they chose to deliver you a
vehicle that's my issue i don't feel
like me choosing to get a vehicle
it should come up
that far off the ground once it hits it
like and the bounce is pretty good it's
just to me it just looks sloppy that's
what i'm saying like i'm not saying that
it bouncing is not realistic it is
realistic especially in a battlefield
they would probably drop that like that
because it
it running isn't really a relative thing
it's getting yourself out of that
situation so you need it as fast as
possible all i'm saying it's a video
game and i do feel like they should have
done that receiving the property back i
got to back you up there it's not
realistic at all if it would have
dropped in real life like that would
have broke a wing it would have freaking
destroyed itself
it just it's funny the way it drops and
bounces and that's all we're saying
those sparks look ridiculous and and
that's that's
and there was one part where i didn't
understand the in the thing and i put it
on my video where uh master chief saves
a girl from a fire fight she gets on the
warthog and then they they just drive
off a cliff drive
like what is going on
i'm just like why why is that even a
thing all right so it was so weird
all right so we got a two dollar
superstar from brap
shout out to the panel salute we got a
two dollar super chat from uh from
optimus back sweat oh my god
uh halo looking fire we got another two
dollar super chat from brap you being
picky addict i'll be picky as much as i
want to be then we got a five dollar
shooter from dollar to toku there's
plenty of things that uh to be picky
about in the trailer but that's not one
of them and then we got a five dollar
stream chat from lorenzo butch use your
name we're gonna move past that the cji
was a teaser for the trailer they
dropped today and they looked a lot of
uh there was a lot of comedy in the
trailer like chief driving off the cliff
and then we got a two dollar superchat
from gaber by uh choice maybe it was
miller time and the pilot had to go i
don't know you got two more got one for
you
that was intentional comedy i i found it
funny i don't think it was i don't think
it was intentional so we got a two
dollar super chat from raiden blaine
every halo game vehicle drop has been
the same
don't make me go look this up right in
blue don't make me go look up halo drops
you're gonna get him down the rabbit
hole oh lord
i'm gonna stay away from that i think
you guys are trying to trigger me man
it's working but i'm gonna stay away
from it we gotta fight all those troops
from alvin the sheer amount of time
spent on these three seconds is crazy
and guess what alvin i spend the whole
damn podcast talking about if i want to
look but we ain't doing that there's
other stuff we could talk about in the
podcast but i will play it one more time
for the chat just one more time like
look at that
look at that man but we gonna move past
that so let's see
yeah
let's let's talk about like
the sandbox in halo infinite i think
it's the best i've ever seen haley yeah
like look at that shot look at this shot
right now that looks so
great but you know what they're failing
to tell you guys the ship is damaged
because of the damn dropping okay we're
moving past it
so i i do think that
the sandbox to this game hasn't it looks
good though in the shots you're showing
but didn't odd and others like with the
cliffs and the rocks are you seeing that
that's what i was trying to say like it
looks off in the trailer and i like this
because like look like i've always felt
like
halo needs to be that that realm of a
soldier doing unrealistic things that
could never happen you know what i'm
saying like because you're a spartan
you're supposed to
be
that person that you send behind enemy
lines that
never fails and he's supposed to be able
to do
abnormal stuff that you never would be
able to do so like what i like is like
look he jumps out of the vehicle shoots
a rocket
yeah it looks awesome and then grabs on
to the other ship
i i i like what they're showing i like
how the way they're portraying the
bandage i did notice some people saying
that this individual is atriox
um anyone who said this is atrialx
you i'm you do you take it out i'm just
gonna you take it out uh this is not
atrialx this is one of atrialx's um
his
his peoples it's not atrialx himself now
i know that's not a lot of your guys's
uh pr fault because
atriox has only been in a um
he's only been in halo wars so i can
understand because you guys don't know
who he is but what i'll do for you guys
what i'll do i don't personally like i
don't personally like the art style of
the characters in in you know halo i
wish it would have got more grittier and
more realistic looking in the approach
to to the graphics but
i will say that for what they're doing
with
what they were going for it looks really
good it looks solid
i don't personally care for the art
style but i get it right
so this is atriox
this this the individual there is not
atrialx like we haven't seen atriox
since
uh since the flood expansion for halo
wars 2. no one knows where this man is
this is not atrialx this is someone else
uh atrialx
would make this dude look like his [ __ ]
atriox is way stronger he's way bigger
he lost weight
if this is atrial
if this is atrialx i quit like this is
look atriox is one of the most
one of the most iconic people that's
been in halo in a long time this better
not be atriox so you know i personally
feel like something's happened to
atrialx i don't know
but you know what i want to ask you guys
is do did you guys like like how they
portrayed the the banished in here
they didn't show much they didn't really
show them yeah
yeah i felt like they did a good job
with the band i felt like
it's it's one of those things where you
know i would really like to see more on
the vanish see seeing all that you know
outside where you're flying in in the
wasp it looks awesome man like the game
looks really good because it looks great
here
yeah even there right now
yeah it looks really good
i i just
my biggest thing guys
i was expecting a train wreck now i
think we can we can agree
i'm pretty sure we can agree that
uh this game probably still going to
come in hard you know but it's not going
to come in as hard as i ever anticipate
here's that part where they go off the
cliff
oh okay okay you let's see the go off
the cliff all right let me save
[Laughter]
what i like about this is where she's
like maybe he's a friendly and he's like
no he's not
yeah it's just did you notice that did
you notice that they have health bars
yeah yeah that's kind of weird it's kind
of interesting just kind of helpful
now i've always wondered uh doesn't
master chief like weigh
like a lot
like
he weighs a lot he's in a suit that i'm
pretty sure weighs over a ton i don't
know how much
identical it might not even weight on
but to me
the the amount
of weight that master chief has i don't
think you would be going towards him he
should be coming towards you see i don't
know right here that we're seeing looks
great man yeah honestly that looks great
yep yeah i don't have a problem with any
of that
and i think that uh for the most part
the health is sad the chat um looks
weird bro i'm there enough like
they're not paying attention like we're
saying stuff like this looks good but
there's other shots clearly i ain't
paying attention to that
there's a ubisoft map
yeah it looks like if if people can't
handle me just having criticism for
certain things i don't know what to tell
you and even just having a good time and
laughing i mean like look at that look
how nice that looks like
i don't that look he just grappled the
coil it just threw it like look how
smooth that transition is
yeah
um like it's fun man that looks fun and
we've already played the multiplayer so
we know how fun the game can be
it's just i want to get in there and see
what the story is like and what the open
world is like what i like is like look
he grapple hooked
the gravity hammer to himself
and then when he had the gravity hammer
he goes into the rpg system and upgrades
it to the camouflage gravity hammer and
then when he boosts right it turns him
invisible i'm curious how they're gonna
work on these and if sooner or later
they might have stuff like pull in from
the actual like single player into the
multiplayer if you get what i'm saying
let me take care of this super chat real
quick before it goes away
um
all right so i read that one we gotta
find out super chat from hot grizz 9110
was halo ever been a graphical showcase
never thought any halos were the best
looking games that came out but it
probably should be look i i i think halo
4 actually looks halo 4.
yeah halo 4 look good and i'm not saying
that like look like we ain't really
talked about the graphics that's the
funny thought funny thing we talked
about the ship coming down and we talked
about the animations
yeah like we just talked about like the
small stuff and it's not necessarily
small i think that's why it's important
i think animations are important but i
do think that you know
uh they're they're like in the middle i
think they're important a lot because
it's the immersion thing
but in the grand scheme of things as
long as the animations are good enough i
think it's fine but it's still criticism
let me chris
you're not
yeah that that's the dude that was like
i'm gonna say you're about to read it
yeah go ahead but you're not having the
same halo game you're not having the
same uh hold up let me read this
criticism is fine but you're not having
the you're not keeping the same energy
for all the halo games you're blinded by
nostalgia the graphics are physics and
are worse in the older games and you
didn't complain about first off first
off porn gamer how the hell you know
what i complained about back then
second off born gamer
i'm complaining now okay
i maybe i was i was i had the tinted
glasses on i agree with you back then
born gamer but guess what ain't no more
chief i'm a called out and guess what
born gamer back then i didn't have a
youtube channel and i wasn't any warning
shape or form into the podcasting scene
but i'm now i do think there has things
that have changed between halo 4
and halo infinite and first off i think
everyone in this panel have i not been
100
on the halo 5
train
everyone in this chat
you guys know that i was the only one
defending halo 5 when it was out so
don't sit there and tell me that i ain't
keeping stuff 100 i've always kept stuff
a hundred percent
yeah no for me it's it look i i love the
halo games and yes even the art style i
have to deal with even if i don't like
it i don't care halo is awesome the
music the the the game play that's why i
play halo
um when it comes to you know infinite
we're not sitting up here saying that
we're we don't like the game or we don't
like what we see
no there's certain things we're just yes
we're nitpicking but at the end of the
day we say it looks fun we can't wait to
play it yeah i'm personally skeptical on
the story and on the open world aspect
but that's just me because 343 for me
hasn't put out a good campaign for me
at the end of the day
we're just nitpicking i know you guys
think we're nitpicking too much
i'm still playing the game and i still
enjoyed it i love what they showed on
whoever that forerunner chick is i love
that there is an elite that goes around
just clapping spartans i i like the
attention to detail
i love the multiplayer i did nothing but
speak positive about the multiplayer
but at the end of the day if you guys
don't want me to criticize stuff
you guys are gonna have to see yourself
out the door i'ma be real with you and i
and this is real talk this isn't
this isn't joking
um
i'm a hundred percent down on everything
if i don't like it i ain't gonna like it
i'm never gonna say i don't like
something when i don't like something me
pointing out
the way that they drop a machine on this
game isn't saying halo's trash it's
saying they could have did a better way
of doing that that's all that is no way
shape or form am i telling that this
game is trash you guys got to be
realistic here and i was even realistic
to a point about the thing be about the
vehicle being dropped all i'm saying is
it could have been done better
i i hated halo 5 story but i played that
game all the way through twice by myself
you know why because
first time i played it was on the xbox
one then i played it on the xbox one x i
wanted to play it through it with all
the nice shiny graphics
but the reason why i played through it
again and why i played it the first time
is because i find halo fun
that's it
you know so you know
it's trying to tell us
what's real criticism what's not real
criticism geez look pole that's how you
know this is this i know that's what i
said this is why when i did my my little
stream i literally was like you know
what guys
y'all take what you want i'm scared
we ain't going to pay attention too much
to the chat like look like
i get it you guys are upset with me man
and it's fine i'll be i'll be the person
that you guys need not the person you
guys want
you know yeah
and i i don't i love halo that's the
crazy part is i have done nothing but
speak positive about halo but the moment
i have a little bit of criticism i know
you're yeah you're the hater like how
dare you it looks amazing you're part of
the pegasus nation now get out oh my god
we ain't talking about the pegasus but
you're part of it now get out
i'm gonna wear i'm gonna wear a pegasus
station shirt
right here
five dollars
hey
i just want to watch uh i just watched
the us air force air drop pump v with
the parachute and that bounced it's
called humvee airdrop from a c-17
okay
i'm not going down that rabbit hole i
know you're trying to generate it okay
look
did it bounce oh okay you know what
we're just letting go
okay we're going fast this way look the
addict is the worst
girlfriend what the hell you guys are
you guys are
trolling me man look bad
i didn't like the way the damn thing
fell on the ground god you got to get
over that but let let's get away from
that i ain't reading the super chat
unless i ain't reading the chat unless
it's a super chat because you guys
aren't happy with me man oh my god
what's crazy is
iop super iop's community
they have no problem super chat and
trash talk either like right so we got a
five dollar super chat from mr irishman
uh saying halo's oprah will be like far
cry is a little disrespectful personally
think it would be more like gears 5's
open world levels is a is a plus for me
uh mr irishman i don't have enough
information to know whether or not it's
like one or the other i need to comment
on that real quick gears 5's open world
there was like nothing in it
it was very sparse there was hardly
anything to do in that open world
except for right around the skiff it was
pretty bland i didn't like that aspect
of it i like gears 5 it was a great game
but i don't i i thought it was there was
a lot of unused space
i don't think halo is not like that i
think halo is going to be more like far
cry as in you're going to go to outposts
and take it over or destroy it and move
on
i think there's going to be a lot of
that
yeah and for the most part
i feel like gears was done very well
besides
the third chapter i actually think gears
is a phenom gears 5 is a phenomenal game
and to this day i
i will
keep up that i will never say i
i loved gears 5. i really did i think
gears 5 was better than halo 5.
i thought gears did a phenomenal story i
enjoyed the story now as multiplayer
might be a little bit a little bit
plastic around me
yeah it might be a little like but that
that single player was was lit uh
obviously we got people uh talking they
they they talk with two dollars from
chat from raiden blade love attic just
having fun with you bro it's all jokes
and i don't take any of this seriously
we got a five dollar super chat from
gamer by choice honestly i am uh play
master chief collection for the first
time and i have to say the vehicle
physics do seem to be off the game looks
fun though salute to the panel gamer by
choice you got to go in hiding after
saying that because this chat will find
you they're going to find you taking so
they
we got a two dollar shooter from
augustus i definitely butchered your
name we're going to move past lucious
i have no problem to pay money to talk
trash that you none of you guys have a
problem man all right so look who she is
as far as halo
i'm will it like i still think the
game's coming in i'll be right with you
i do still think in some way shape or
form the game is still coming in hot but
i think it's it's a little bit of a like
it's just like
like in a plane when you're coming down
and there's something wrong with the
landing uh landing them you're still
gonna land fine for the most part you
know there obviously there are some uh
tragedies in that scenario but you're
gonna land it's gonna be a little bumpy
lied i'm gonna be real with you
two months ago i thought this was a
crash landing like i thought it was
gonna come out with a great multiplayer
and that single player was gonna be
hiccups now i have a lot more faith in
the single player regardless what the
people in the chat having an issue with
my grav uh my physics engine
regardless what you guys have to say um
i still i think i have a lot more
faith in this than i did before i saw
this trailer we got a two dollars for
matthew griffin griffish i don't know
griffin only issue with particle and
energy effects i agree with you
it needs to be two yeah
yeah those need to be definitely fixed
so i think now
we can get off a little bit especially
with people like forte
i don't think that 343 is out of the
woodworks yet i still think they need to
somewhat land this halo infinite thing i
do think there's going to be a lot of
issues that's fixed post launch such as
the co-op experience such as ray traces
just as forge i do believe that there is
a battle royale coming i'm still
convinced of that i don't think it's
launch it's probably a year later six
months yet later
i do think that's coming down the road i
think war zone will eventually come back
uh that's my personal opinion but i do
think that
they have shown enough on the single
player that i'm not going to pressure
them to show more if they want to show
me more that's fine but i think i see
people on twitter saying you know what's
funny
people are
attacked us for 20 minutes talking about
that but now i'm about to hype the hell
out of this game it's gonna be nothing
but you write addicts in the chat
i do think they have showed me enough of
this game that i'm confident i do think
they have done enough of this game that
i feel like they have something that
they might be able to savage on here and
i think the people that are on twitter
saying that they should have shown more
what did you want to see the whole damn
game
like they showed you this trailer they
showed you how the mission structure is
going to happen they showed you how the
map structure is going to happen they
showed you even
probably the antagonist the chick that
was that was talking down to the four
rudders they showed you spartan hunters
in this game we don't know if that's a
faction or that's one person they showed
you quite a bit so i am kind of curious
what you guys have to say let me get
this super chat real quick on what
before you get that i i gotta let you
know i gotta go i gotta go pick up my
daughter but it was good to hang out
with you today man thank you for letting
me join you i i always love joining the
the lords any way i can
uh i support you guys you know that and
bit of course same to you brother it was
nice to uh be able to sit on the panel
with you today so appreciate you chat uh
always a good time even if we don't
agree chat i love you guys and i i'll
see some of you tonight on already
at the end of the day man regardless at
this chat a little extra with me
i know that this chat isn't toxic you
know what i'm saying yeah that that's
the the most important thing to me i i
see you later fawns uh so we got a five
dollar super chat from uh black rider
compared to where 343 was two years ago
halo is looking great i have to
completely 100 agree with you we got a
five dollar super chat from rob jones i
think that's probably but i'm gonna say
dollar because it's all i know man going
to go through the whole franchise just
before halo infinite comes out can't
wait for co-op is there to be spoilers
100 soon as co-op is out i'll be there
you know what kid smoothies you're still
there we're gonna have to stream the
halo franchise
uh before the game comes out i know that
probably he ain't doing that because he
never wants to do anything i want to do
but um we got a five dollars from rob
jones and thank you for all the content
you put out bit
addict and lords and fawns appreciate
all the love you guys give we got a two
live streamers have a raven blade only
the haters wanted more to be shown i
agree with you know we're not going to
have this too much longer we're sitting
in about an hour and a half i want to
maybe 10-15 more minutes uh but big
cloud what is your expectations for halo
infinite now that you've seen a little
bit more on the story
uh so
on the multiplayer side i think they're
good so nothing to worry about there in
terms of single player i do have more
faith now
because we were all 50 50 when we were
going into this we're like okay that
multiplayer is fine right but
now i'm a little i have a little bit
more faith in them with the uh single
player so we'll see what's up obviously
the features are not there they're gonna
be added later
it's all about just you know really
knocking out the park you know i mean a
straight shot that's all they need to do
if they can do that i think that will
fix all the the issues personally i
think there's going to be some form of
issues when the game launches you think
but
i do and i don't even talk about
anything drastic you know i'm talking
maybe some connection issues with the
multiplayer
but i do think that i do think this
game's gonna i think it's gonna review
well like
especially if they get that far cry
if they take that far cry
formula and they adapt it and make it
that make they make it to make sense for
halo
and you know i already see that because
in far cry you know you can
fly around and stuff but
the crazy stuff i saw in that trailer if
that's your everyday type of gameplay
for halo infinite in terms of the
sandbox i think it's going to do what i
think people are going to have fun and i
think at the end of the day that's
what's the most important is the
enjoyment people don't talk about
enjoying games anymore you know i think
that there's this box that people want
to talk nothing about what they didn't
like it and you know what i myself
you know
i'm guilty of it sometimes too where i
focus on the bad and not the good like
clearly people made fun of me for
talking about the the [ __ ] falling
and that that's cool all that's jokes
but you know i think that halo infinite
is a good spot i think 343 is in a good
spot i've never been on that that that
movement uh bit cloud where people feel
like halo infinite needs to be given
halo needs to be given to another friend
another developer i've always said halo
infinite is
probably in a more p competent though
did you say something like that you want
to get compensated i i want i want more
i'm making this game and not the
community from three four three i want
more i'm staying on my score and i'm not
changing things drastically every game
because certain people didn't like it
i think they have a good middle ground
and i think it's going to look good i i
think that you know there is gonna be a
little bit inconsistency with where the
way the game looks but i'm not looking
for this game in terms of graphics i'm
looking this game in terms of gameplay
and i think the gameplay is gonna be
solid
but you know
let's talk about metacritic and then
we're going to get out of here
bitcloud
give me a three point range on the
metacritic score
personally uh
they can't they can't hit no
i would have to say i would i would i
would expect this to be
at least like an 80 something 84.
i think 85 to 88
85 yeah i don't i don't think like i
don't have no crazy
yeah 85 to 88 yeah i don't i don't i
don't have no crazy expedition that this
is going to be a 90. i don't think i
don't i don't either am i but i might be
wrong
you know that that single player might
hit like it depends how they tell that
narrative
if there is lore behind who this new
person is that there is a beginning
middle and end to the story that they're
going to be playing in this and if
they're able to really give lore behind
the the person who goes around killing
uh spartans that's trying to kill
spartans the new chick that's gone up
there's laura behind the new uh there's
a really good character development with
the new pilot there's character
development with master chief going on
cortana they speak really good on what's
going on with cortana this could easily
get a 90 and above but it just depends
on the execution yeah it has a legit for
like a leveler like resident evil remake
i mean like
all out they went all out this is what
this is what you guys been waiting for
type of thing and if it's that then
we're supposed to we're going to see 95s
we're going to see 96s and all that
personally though
i think in an 85 86
maybe 87 is about right i think that's
that's right so yeah it's about what i
want the chat i want the chat we're
going to give it about three or four
minutes because i want to you know
briefly see what you guys are feeling g
give me a good three
points like 80 80 something to 80
something 70 something three point
narratives i want to see what you guys
feel that hey look
metacritic isn't the end all be all but
i do think it has its place
and i do think it is an overall you know
since uh senses of where the industry
feels about the game i think there's a
lot of issues with
metacritic there's a lot grinnell
brought that up remember we talked yeah
i thought to christophernell and i
talked to him as well man but he said
metacritic does play a bigger role than
a lot of people
under don't understand when it comes to
these uh
games so and definitely hit that like
button if you guys don't mind 220 some
people in here definitely hit that like
button it was a pretty rocky show at the
beginning with uh me getting everything
together uh you know oh you mean but
it's been a great pulled out the thing
that's just that
that's just all comedic relief really i
didn't have to do that i
it's all about entertainment man i want
to make people laugh but you know at the
end of the day
i personally feel like this game is
going to do well it looks like for the
most part people think it's going to be
a mid 80 to high eddie game i think i
think that's pretty accurate i don't
think it's going to be a 70 game uh i'd
be very surprised if it's a 70 game i
think the 70 that's when we we come back
to this conversation and we just flat
out save three we have a completely
different goal
yeah yeah yeah three four three has to
go at that point but you know
when it comes to you know we're going to
go ahead and end it uh i want to make
sure fawns gets his his rose definitely
go check fawns out uh he's on youtube uh
fonzerelli uh check him out on rdx
tonight he's going to be on there i'm
sure they're gonna have a lot of uh you
know talking a lot about halo uh big
cloud gaming what's going on what do you
have set up i know you got something set
up what's going on oh of course man of
course appreciate the invites um glad i
caught this the last second when i saw
your message um
yeah uh we have a lot happening for your
boy um
i already said this earlier with fonz uh
on the show but i didn't hear us you
know during the whole halo
conversation but um
i was contacted by ign so i'll be
working ign on some projects so i'm
looking forward to that on
their platform but as far as content is
concerned have a massive interview for
november 5th
obviously this friday rgt we have a
special guest um got two i'm gonna tell
you right now one of them is dealer uh
pretty much at this point so we're gonna
have them on the show um you guys can
find me big cloud gaming youtube
twitch twitter
all that jazz we interviewed kate yeager
on our last show last friday so if you
guys want to check that out glad we'll
check that out
awesome show man very insightful learned
a lot about xbox and
how this industry works so yeah
pretty good yeah and keep in mind uh i
will be streaming tomorrow i'm going to
try picking up streaming a lot more i
enjoy streaming
i think i enjoy streaming more than i
enjoy making content these days like i
don't know maybe i'm just
i'm just odd on the content in terms of
that
i want to make more opinion pieces on
videos like opinions on certain topics
but i do think i want to pick up a lot
more on streaming i'm going to be doing
that on the iron lures podcast twitch
channel uh so definitely be looking out
for that i appreciate it for coming
through uh definitely go check him out
let me grab his twitter information real
quick for you guys make sure big cloud
gets his uh
his flowers uh and i will actually put
the um
fawns in there as well but i appreciate
them for coming through man we'll see
you guys next week um
my uh my co-host he he got
he got caught up at work so shout out to
wholesale definitely go check him out uh
he'll be back next week but i appreciate
everyone coming out man we're gonna call
it a day uh we're out of here
you know
i i i closed out of the ship falling i
was gonna do that one more time right
before i left but i closed it out so
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
deal with it man you guys talk to you
guys like